[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission le débat c'est une mesure
impopulaire et pourtant le gouvernement
a confirmé hier sa volonté de baisser la
vitesse de 10 km heure sur l'ensemble
des routes secondaires bidirectionnelle
sans séparation de voix l'enjeu diminuer
le nombre de morts la gravité des
accidents et la pollution
pourtant cet argument ne convainc pas
manifestation de motards la trouve être
ouverte de 28 présidents de départements
et proposition de loi de députés de
l'opposition
rien ne semble aujourd'hui empêcher
l'application de cette mesure au 1er
juillet prochain mais rouler à 80
km/heure au lieu de 90 sur certaines
routes secondaires
est ce vraiment efficace pour diminuer
le nombre d'accidents mortels
pour répondre à cette question chacun
autour de moi jean yves petit directeur
départemental de l'association de
prévention routière sur norbert pierrot
porte-parole de l'association victimes
et citoyens
et enfin luc pelletier coordinateur de
l'antenne yvelinoise de la fédération
française des motards en colère
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur ce plat
tout alors 3477 et le nombre de
personnes décédées sur les routes en
france en 2016
le bilan provisoire de 2017 ce fait part
d'une légère hausse de ce chiffre
dans les yvelines nous sommes à aux
alentours nous sommes exactement à 49
morts en 2017 soit une personne de plus
qu'en 2016 selon la préfecture des
yvelines le premier facteur de mortalité
sur les routes du département et
l'alcool et les stupéfiants dans un
accident sur trois suivi de la vitesse
présent dans un accident sur cinq alors
nous allons tout de suite faire un début
de consensus autour de cette table
pourquoi la diminution de la vitesse sur
les routes secondaires qui sont pourtant
les plus accidentogènes ne vous
satisfait pas qui souhaitent commencer
sur ça va alors pour nous à victimes et
citoyens c'est pas ce n'est pas une
mesure qui nous satisfait pas mais c'est
pas une mesure qui nous satisfait non
plus alors là je vais expliquer je peux
pas faire deux
moi je vais l'expliquer en fait nous
avions déjà des limitations de vitesse
130 km/heure sur route 90 sur nationale
cependant il n'y a pas cinq ans sur
l'autoroute que sur les routes
départementales importante à la personne
heures c'est vrai 50 et 30 essais on
aurait peut-être dû essayer déjà de
maintenir les vitesses et d'avoir des
contrôles sur les 90 km heure en ayant
certainement peut-être une position plus
accrue des gendarmes et des forces de
l'ordre sur les routes ce que l'on
réclame déjà depuis très longtemps
d'accord et qui naît est inexistant si
vous croisez une voiture de police sur
les routes dans les yvelines par jour
c'est vraiment où un contrôle il y en a
quand même très peu de jours c'est
vraiment la bonne heure du jour est ce
que vous vous êtes d'accord avec soit
alors le
l'association prévention routière
approuve la mesure 80 km/heure telles
restrictions
laissez moi qu'à cliquer elle
l'approuvent ce n'est pas une idée qui
vient de nous elle a été annoncée au
dernier comité interministériel de la
sécurité routière du mois de janvier
nous l'avons probablement découverte à
ce moment là ainsi que tous les
partenaires
donc l'association prévention routière
approuve en regrettant toutefois que
l'expérimentation est pas été menées
plus longuement vous savez qu'il ya une
expérimentation pendant deux ans sur
quelques dizaines de kilomètres à la
ronde nous ne connaissons pas don du
moins les résultats n'apparaissent pas
flagrant donc nous aurions aimé avoir un
peu plus de recul sur cette affaire là
et maintenant
disons que la mesure ne peut pas nuire
pour vous si on diminue la vitesse
forcément il y aura moins d'accidents
mortels
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit ça peut pas
nuire je ne suis pas convaincu que ça
apportera beaucoup de beaucoup de vies
épargnées mais en tout cas il est
logique que ça peut pas nuire - va vite
- les accidents sont violents c'est une
évidence
la fédération française des motards
calais ça pour ma colère qu'elle a sa
position elle est claire nous sommes
contre vous êtes le joueur on est en
colère quand se justifie constructif
aussi est aussi citoyen voilà donc comme
ça on a résumé le cde bien sur cette
mesure on est contre 80 m 80 km heure
mais plus globalement nous sommes nous
opposons à cette politique de sécurité
routière que qu'impose le gouvernement
de façon unilatérale
il faut savoir que cette mesure a été
prise à l'issue du cicr par 'le premier
ministre qui s'est engagé même
personnellement sur sur le dossier et
que nous on estime que prendre des
mesures sans l'avis d'eads et des élus
qui représentent le peuple et des
associations représentatives dont
certaines sont sont autour de la table
qui n'a pas fait une erreur est une
erreur fondamentale est une erreur
fondamentale
donc ne nous opposons plus à une
politique globale de sécurité routière
telle qu'elle est appliquée non
seulement par ce gouvernement mais par
les gouvernements précédents et gaza
c'est dans la forme mais sur le fond sur
le fond de la mesure de la vitesse
écoutez
l'étude le gouvernement se base sur une
étude qui date de cinquantaine d'années
de 50 ans en suède sur deux deux
chercheurs qui ont un jour pensé qu'
appliquer le dit mission d' inviter à se
dire le nombre de tués c'est évident
c'était appliqué par moments la suède
est passée une conduite de gauche à
droite donc voyez c'était très très
ciblé deux années d'expérimentation
alors chercheur si chargeurs ont donc on
fait ou fait un algorithme et on en
arrive à la situation que pour qu'il y
ait zéro tué en france il faudrait tous
roulé à 12 km heure de l'est les ratures
scientifiques qui prouvent cela non et
puis l'expérimentation qui a été mené
sur 80 kilomètres on y reviendra
peut-être doute alors elle est son
fondement d'ailleurs on a eu beaucoup de
mal et les associations ont eu beaucoup
de mal à obtenir les résultats de cette
expérimentation fait sur 80 km 1 et
d'ailleurs le résultat est que on a plus
constaté effectivement une baisse déjà
de la vitesse plutôt que une analyse et
des résultats concrets sur
l'accidentologie
voilà non mais je pense que maintenant
ce qu'il faut peut-être voir aussi c'est
que effectivement un petit peu d'auteurs
c'est que et je suis assez d'accord avec
avec monsieur diminuer la vitesse avoir
un accident j'ai quelques que j'ai eu
malheureusement automatiquement
effectivement diminué de 90 à 80 de
véhicules qui ce don qui se percutent de
face sans terre plein central parce que
c'est prévu
effectivement théoriquement
théoriquement on doit avoir une
diminution des morts et des blessés
graves
c'est mathématique on est tous d'accord
c'est logique c'est mathématique c'est
logique puisque 12 kilos mais si on peut
maintenant avec des voitures comme elle
elles sont modernes comme avec les
airbags et c'est théoriquement c'est une
bonne mesure on est tous d'accord nous
tous les trois autour de ces tables pour
avoir quand même moins de man sur les
routes
nous sommes bien sur ce coup
ce qu'il faut faire c'est travailler
ensemble effectivement essayé d'avoir
des communications avec lego le
gouvernement lorsqu'ils font des mesures
comme ça pour voir leur expliquez moi ce
que je trouve regrettable cette mesure
vous voyez la semaine prochaine je vais
dans une entreprise je vais avoir 300
salariés en face de moi je vais leur
expliquer ce qu'est un accident de la
route va automatiquement quand je vais
me retrouver face à eux ils vont me dire
écoutez voilà ce qui se passe les 80 km
et c'est les radars pompes à fric et ben
ça c'est embêtant que ce à dire que le
message le message en sont sûrs a passé
alors c'est exactement la dernière
phrase que vous n'êtes prononcé c'est
exactement la position de notre
association
cette mesure ne
ne fonctionnera que si effectivement les
gens sont convaincus et réduisent la
vitesse et moi j'ai déjà dis d'ailleurs
à votre antenne il ya deux ans quand on
avait commencé à parler de ça ça nous ça
ne peut marcher que si il y a
effectivement aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'accidents entre 80 et 90 km heure dans
ce cas là oui effectivement ça aura un
sens mais si les accidents dus à la
vitesse sont déjà à 100 120 kilomètres
heure comme de toute façon c'est déjà au
delà de cette limitation de vitesse ça
changera rien d'accord et donc ça ne
marchera que si effectivement la vitesse
est effectivement réduite que tout le
monde l'appliquent je dirais qu'on ne
fait pas une politique de sécurité
routière contre l'usagé mais avec les
usagers avec avec des usagers mais aussi
avec les associations qui représentent
ses usagers c'est à vous est aussi
d'accord pour un contrôle accru
notamment sur leurs hôtes
ecoutez-nous la fédération française des
motards en colère on a toujours
privilégié depuis 40 ans près de 40 ans
une politique de formation de
responsabilisation sur le comportement
des individus
nous on pense que c'est d'abord le
comportement qui doit être travaillé sur
sur les personnes pour arriver à
effectivement l'objectif commun que de
toutes les associations et même du
gouvernement de 10 mai le nombre de tués
sur les routes mais comment fait-on ça
parce que ça fait quand même quelques
années comme
de mort stagne et pourtant il ya
toujours autant de square habitat pour
dire qu'il faut pas téléphoné il faut
pas leur avis aux à votre avis donc en
tant d'émoi écoutez je viens de le dire
déjà le comportement ci va écouter ya
peut-être une part les pré version alors
le dialogue par les coups qu'il aimait
et la sanction très important je voulais
ajouter que autant le gouvernement est
capable de mettre en place des
programmes de formation des del'école
primaire par rapport aux problèmes de
radicalisation on a entendu parler ça se
fera face rap à milan par l'auto quand
il veut le faire pourquoi pourquoi
depuis que moi je fais de la moto il ya
près de 40 ans pourquoi elle je n'ai pas
vu pour mes enfants par exemple un
programme de formation à la sécurité
routière dès l'école primaire qui
pourrait déboucher sur un diplôme ou au
moins une épreuve à un examen
pourquoi parce que si nos jeunes demain
on leur explique que la route doit être
partagée spécialisé la demande
oui donc je suis pas je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord tant mieux il existe quand
même déjà un programme depuis les années
50 puisque c'est une démission de
l'éducation nationale l'éducation
routière en milieu scolaires écoles
collèges lycées est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut lire sa force là ça existe ça
existe déjà
l'éducation nationale s'appuie sur sur
nous sur nos associations pour faire ce
travail et c'est notre boulot quotidien
donc on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'existe
rien en plus il existe vous savez des
petits examen attestation scolaire de
sécurité routière qu'ils sont
kiki qui sont menées par l'éducation
nationale qui sanctionne alors c'est pas
très compliqué évidemment qui sanctionne
ses leçons fin cette éducation routière
donc ça existe déjà il faut certainement
aller plus loin mais
je pense que c'est déjà pas mal après
yaya le permis de conduire lui même qui
a déjà qui a beaucoup évolué aussi c'est
totalement l'éducation c'est plus se
continuer sur le permis de conduire les
actions d'appréhension au tiers sont
loin je n'y peux effectivement qu'il ya
des programmes mais je pense qu'on doit
aller beaucoup plus loin
si on veut vraiment c'est obligatoire
des programmes des programmes scolaires
et puis et écoutez moi j'ai été à
l'école
à part faire du vélo sur une petite
piste cyclable je me souviens pas très
bien de ce que ça voulait dire que quand
j'ai passé mes permis aux voitures et
motos
je me souviens pas très bien de ce que
voulait dire rouler à moto dans un
environnement d'autres véhicules
parce que la route que je le disais la
route se partage et la route doit être
comprise vous savez que c'est réponse
les choses ça joue ça a ajouté que les
les personnes qui ont le moins
d'accidents sur la route et ça c'est
prouvé par les assureurs ce sont les
personnes qui ont plusieurs permis c'est
à dire qu'ils peuvent qui ont permis
voiture mois les mieux formés pourquoi
parce que ils connaissent les usages d d
d autres véhicules et peuvent de ce fait
anticiper et mieux comportée sur la
route
réponse non mais je suis d'accord avec
vous mais alors moi je veux je vais
beaucoup dans les collèges dans les
lycées
effectivement effectivement il ya une
écoute et contrairement à ce que moi je
pensais j'en ai fait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup et je pensais que lés
coutaller pas être aussi importante
qu'elle l'est et les jeunes sont allés
coûte tout à fait non j'ai fait je fais
je fais je fais part apporte par rapport
à l'accident
par rapport à mon expérience me dit
voilà ce qui s'est passé j'ai j'ai on
est 2 en général un collègue mounir qui
est avec moi quel ton fauteuil
moi j'ai une canne mais là il ya un
fauteuil d'envoyer déjà quand on se
présente en tant qu est ce qu ils
changent entre justement dans des jeunes
qui vous écoute et puis ensuite des
salariés qui sont complètement fermé à
vos discours pattes
chose qui change qu'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est que ronald problème quelque part
de l'ascension de la pompe à fric qui
vient un petit peu dérouté le message
pour vous même vous demander plus de
contrôle oui mais je demande plus de
contrôles de contrôler le le gendarme si
vous voulez le le policier sur le banc
d'aloses pas pour sanctionner forcément
mais regardez vous mettez un gendarme
automates automatiquement vous allez
avoir une diminution de la vitesse
parce qu'il va être là dans le sang et
qui fait à présent exactement
il va être présent pas pour sanctionner
mais la présence et moi je pense que
pour rebondir ce que disait tout à
l'heure où l'udc c'est que il ya eu
aujourd'hui il ya un problème aussi dans
la société mais je crois pas à la
société un problème de civisme
ça te fait de sueur ça pourrait même
décider bien sûr je retrouve chez
évidemment un problème de civisme donc
comme vous le disiez les deux piliers
doivent aller progresser ensemble
la prévention d'un côté et la répression
aussi qui est absolument indispensable
en grande bretagne par exemple que ce
serait bien qu'on parle un peu des
autres pays européens
pour comparer en grande bretagne qui ont
de huy qui ont de bien meilleurs
résultats en grande bretagne en france
alors il ya plein de raisons
mais entre autres les sanctions sont
beaucoup plus sévères en grande bretagne
qu'en france d'accord dans pour vous si
le coup de bâton était plus dur s'arrête
plus et faire en fait je pense que oui
je pense qu à toi je pense que la liste
d'accords pour l'alcool pour beaucoup de
choses auraient certainement de l'effet
oui d'accord oui alors juge le module
est quand même effectivement la
répression doit doit être existé pour
une certaine catégorie de personnes
notamment des récidivistes
mais encore une fois les programmes
d'éducation font que demain des jeunes
qui seront formés seront beaucoup plus
sensibilisés à l'eau fait de ne pas de
se conduire en citoyen quoi et
responsable sur tous donc on ne revient
au comportement etc en jeu quand je
j'entends mes collègues autour de la
table on a abandonné un petit peu le 80
km heure pour parler de comportement et
d'individus de civisme
vous voyez que par ce biais le
gouvernement actuel fait fausse route
par rapport à son choix unilatéral sur
le 80 km et le problème principal
problème de comportement caisse oui mais
il ya tout verge et vous avez le parce
qu'on parle de 84 ans mais ses 18
mesures qui ont été prises par le csr de
janvier annoncée par le gouvernement
dans ses divisions mesure par exemple
nous motards on ne rejette pas tout on
retrouve une bonne mesure le fait de
sanctionner le
la conduites avec téléphone téléphone au
volant
parce que nous sommes une des premières
victimes de ce type de comportement et
d'autres mesures qui sont aussi qu'ils
sont qu'il soit aussi intéressante dont
une qui concerne les jeunes qu'on vous
qui les parents afin convoqué invité les
parents quand un jeune est formé à la
conduite de son cyclo et c'est pour
qu'il y ait un dialogue s'instaure enfin
s'instaure et nous c'est ce que nous
pratiquons dans nos centres de formation
de mutuelle des motards et de formation
au niveau du comportement pour vous
alors partagé oui oui je partage
totalement l'analyse
je vais juste partir sur une autre biais
tout en restant actuellement sur le
sujet j'ai parlé du coup le coup changé
et pas d'eau parce que donc on rencontre
souvent le ministre délégué il nous dit
malheureusement restrictions budgétaires
restrictions budgétaires le coup de
changer les panneaux je sais plus
combien ces deux millions d'euros
effectivement il ya leurs gagnants
aujourd'hui regardez les tags et
actuellement je ne sais pas je prends
par exemple mon fils qu'étant au lycée
il a quelques camarades pas très loin
d'ici qui prennent un scooter à deux
roues motorisés pour aller au lycée
regardez les nids-de-poule qui en ce
moment partout suite au gel suite au
salage c'est alors c'est réparé et petit
à petit on met des rustines mais
n'empêche qu'en ce moment même nous en
voiture on a daily de poule donc voyez
la sécurité elle est partout dans c à
vous êtes prêts à payer davantage
d'impôts justement pour venir en aide au
budget du conseil département je pense
que déjà les radars amène déjà pas mal
d'argent je pense maintenant commencer
distribué 11 au sol et à l'état
communique là dessus mais oui vous
son rebond d'hier pour rebondir sur le
problème de l'argent dépensé en tant que
média vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que le
gouvernement pour faire passer sa mesure
qu'ils rejetaient par deux tiers des
français quand même le savoir a dépensé
a dépensé 1 million 600 mille euros pour
communiquer dans 300 médias nationaux et
régionaux double page couleur ça un
million et je dis aux éditeurs c'est un
million six cent mille euros de l'argent
des contribuables qui sert à faire
valider quelque chose que les français
rejettent la ensuite le premier ministre
très clairement dès que s'il devait être
impopulaires pour sauver des vies et
justement faire en sorte qu'il y ait
plus de sécurité sur les routes il
assumait il assure me sauve tellement ça
je pense qu'il a fait une grosse bêtise
on prononce a personnellement pour lui
d'accord pense que la tuerie lors il a
réduit il aurait dû être plus prudent
dans ses propos
est-ce qu'on peut revenir notamment sur
les problèmes de comportement parce
qu'après tout on a parlé beaucoup des
enfants mais en fait ce sont des adultes
qui songe de son volant est-ce que vous
avez chacun d'entre vous dans votre
association dans vos associations vous
avez pu constater qu'il y avait un
relâchement ou de mauvais comportements
au volant justement qu'ils peuvent
expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
on n'arrive pas à diminuer le nombre
naturel alors
nous allons nous aussi beaucoup dans les
entreprises et contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure où il me
semble que les salariés dans les
entreprises sont quand même pas mal sont
bien aller coûte évidemment radars
pompes à fric ça revient régulièrement
c'est sûr que ça nuit un peu là la
cohérence d'un autre à notre message il
mais pour tout le reste tous les
principaux les principales causes
d'accidents qu'on a à peine évoqué tout
à l'heure qui sont bien connus à la
vitesse l'alcool la drogue le téléphone
l'inattention des créations général les
mauvais comportements les queues de
poisson les griller les feux rouges et
tout ça je trouve que les les gens sont
quand même assez assez réceptifs et
notre association fed et des stages de
récupération de points que tout le monde
connaît bien sûr beaucoup de gens m'ont
dit à l'issue de ces stages assez
drôlement bien j'ai appris plein de
choses je reviendrai volontiers je
dirais n'allons pas jusque là mais tant
que les gens sont quand même réceptif je
trouve encore une mesure une mesure
comprise est une mesure acceptée en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence celle du
80e pour venir se renseigner
elle n'est pas comprise donc encore une
fois les gens ne ne seront pas enclin à
accepter
de fait cette situation un kiki qui plus
est le risque de créer des situations
dangereuses par ce gouvernement en
décrétant ce 4 2 m eur n'a pas précisé
si les camions ou le raeo à 80 ou moins
comme aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
j'aurai un delta de 10 km heure entre
véhicules automobiles et camions et les
jeunes permis qui eux aussi étaient dix
kilomètres en dessous
aujourd'hui tel que la mesure est
va être appliquée c'est tout le monde à
80 sur la route
débrouillez vous c'est pour un problème
pour nous bon bah écoutez rendez-vous si
quelquefois par malchance par malheur la
mesure était appliquée rendez vous sans
leur route et bonne chance parce que
nous nous sommes vraiment persuadé parce
que et en plus ce moteur on a intérêt à
ce que notre sécurité soit assurée eh
bien nous on pense sincèrement que cette
mesure va aggraver la situation
d'accord pour voile sera
contre-productif contreproductif d'en
pia autre chose aussi jeu eu un
petit peu donc ça fait un petit peu mal
mais autre chose aussi qui est important
c'est que vous avez de plus en plus de
gens à se faire prendre par derdar à
perdre un point de plérin points deux
points
et qu'est-ce qui se passe au final c'est
vous avez de plus en plus de gens à
rouler sans permis de conduire
6 en misant sur l'autre six cent mille
annoncé enfin c'est un chiffre un peu
plus oui et c'est les chiffres et gens
là ces personnes là qui roulent sans
permis parce qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de civisme donc je réponds
quelque part alors à votre question
ces gens là ne sont pas assurés bien sûr
automatiquement parce que les seuils les
assurances ne couvrent pas un accident
très grave comme le mien au niveau du
corporel c'est des années et des années
et des années de procédures je peux vous
dire qu'il faut plutôt avoir un très bon
avocat et des bons cabinet y en a quand
même pas beaucoup sur la place de paris
et il faut être bien armé donc 5 6 faut
le savoir
c'est la réalité c'est ce que l'on dit
au quotidien nous victimes de la route
les victimes ne sont pas du tout
malheureusement c'est un autre débat
mais les victimes sont totalement
délaissées totalement d'accord
oui on les prend la parole de total
oui alors pour revenir sur le 80 km
heure je l'évoqué tout à l'heure ce
serait bien et moi de la faim parce que
l'accord va très bien alors qu'on
regarde un peu ce qui se passe à
l'étranger dans les autres pays
européens
j'ai regardé un peu en préparant cette
cette émission là il apparaît qu'il ya
déjà plusieurs petits pays
petitjean temps superficie 1 qui
applique cette mesure la suisse
l'irlande je crois qu'à le danemark
aussi les pays-bas la france est le
premier grand pays en superficie à
l'appliquer et les vitesses sont en
europe très très disparates
enfin sur ce type de route 1 la plupart
ces 90 km heure
quelques pays c'est 80 comme je les dis
essentiellement des petits pays mais par
exemple l'allemagne et la grande
bretagne qui ont de bien meilleurs
résultats que nous dans le domaine de la
sécurité routière chez eux c'est 100
km/heure sur ce type de route donc la
mesure on verra bien ce qu'elle donnera
en tout cas le gouvernement après une
décision qui n'est pas populaire donc
est assez courageuse faut quand même
reconnaître sa est le premier grand pays
en surface à appliquer cette mesure nous
verrons ce que ça donnera en deux mots
nous motor fédération française des
motards en colère on ne lâchera rien
jusqu'au mois de juillet et même au delà
faut le savoir
ce genre de manifestation toutes les
semaines il n'ya pas deux semaines en
france sur une ville où il n'y a pas de
manifestation qui rassemble plusieurs
milliers de motards et que je voudrais
juste dire que nous et avec les autres
associations autour de la table et au
delà on réclame la tenue d'états
généraux de la sécurité routière dont
laquelle toutes les parties seront
présentées pourront s'exprimer pour
qu'enfin un dialogue d'une communication
et des résultats soient validés pour
qu'enfin on ait une politique de
sécurité routière intelligente et qui
aboutissent à un nombre de tués qui
diminue significativement
conclure également moi je trouve que
c'est dommage d'avoir amené cette loi au
forceps et qui est anti populaires il
aurait mieux valu avant toute chose
dialoguer avec les gens prendre
dialoguer avec nous association nous
sommes sur le terrain et nous poser la
question de savoir si c'était une bonne
ou une mauvaise mesure fut maintenant
moi je ne souhaite qu'une chose ce soit
une bonne mesure et qui est moins deux
morts et moins de blessés parce que ce
sera le mois de la fin merci beaucoup à
vous toutes avoir aperçu la mission
quant à vous je vous invite à voir et
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet
passer une agréable soirée et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]